on friday jun 24 2011 thousands gathered
outside New York City's Stonewall Inn
awaiting the new york state Senate's
vote on a bill that would legalize gay
marriage in New York State 42 years ago
this weekend following a brutal an
all-too-common raid on the stone wall by
the NYPD a spontaneous uprising of gay
citizens fought back against this
government sanctioned harassment
culminating in a series of riots the
establishment of Gay Pride weekend's all
over the world and the slow and steady
march toward equal protection under the
law the Stonewall is now widely
considered the birthplace of the modern
gay rights movement 39-33 29
a jubilant sense of liberation was in
the air but for many it was just a
relief that the government was finally
getting out of their way it's very
important now is that when couple get
married together when God forbid one
partner died the other partner can get
the pension the other partner don't need
to pay taxes it's a big burden of taxes
even enjoying the town and even in
apartment you know it's fine it's great
that people can celebrate being in love
that's way but I think when it's not
good for the state to be involved in
relationships one thing what I love
about community is that we have a lot of
different ways of relationships and
marriage is just one model and I worry
about this marginalizing everyone else
who's not interested or single it's just
ultimately the historic vote of 33 229
swung on governor andrew Cuomo's
appealed to several libertarian-leaning
republican senators as New York
Magazine's Chadwick Matlin road when you
strip away the cultural and identity
politics gay marriage is really just a
fight about whether the government
should be allowed to regulate personal
liberty